twitch plays Dutch heaven is pretty good
at oh yeah it's like an action so I can
we didn't have any camels it guys I'm in
this market palace dutch ovens pretty
good touch oven what's your guys problem
with camel plight beard Sam no goatee
bro
camel fights too much like clothes what
about napkin tank you guys and that can
take two guys I really like this more
than just letting some guys guys look
got it guys hold on a sec okay it's
awesome that we're finally working
together we've been trying to put this
together for a while right but if we're
gonna make a game it's got to be the
game it needs to be something new but
something that the community is gonna
get really excited about something
that's better than eating RPG what about
a golf game horrible it's all sounds
great you guys really good ideas I can't
wait to get started
so you are you back on the juice Tim
uh you know yeah I'd let it go on the
holidays a little bit but back on it
right right so uh so I mean we gotta
move to figure out a new title for us to
work great as soon as I get some juice
in me that helps me concentrate well Tim
if you're looking for inspiration I
brought five gallons of 50% off candy
from a hardware nothing I just got on
the juice what Tim I'm sure good mystic
juice really helps me concentrate we
need to think clearly now they have a
really good idea why is it this has to
mean pumpkin juice let's get to the
heart filled with lots of free radicals
no you're thinking of cauliflower idiot
I know now what we must do